Si les personnes de 65 ans et
plus travailler autant
commandant Horiot, ce serait
réglé.
- Après une carrière
comme technicien de chauffage,
Marius Poirier travaille
à temps partiel depuis un an
dans une quincaillerie,
une façon de se désennuyer et
de gagner un peu plus d'argent.
Pour l'homme de 67 ans,
la retraite n'est pas
pour bientôt.
MARIUS POIRIER, employé, Rona
- On va prendre ça une année
à la fois. Tant que je vais être
en forme et que je ne serai pas
malade, ça va très bien,
je vais continuer à travailler.
NADINE CHIASSON, dir. nationale,
acquisition de talents, Lowe's
- Il y a des magasins
qui ont jusqu'à 10-15 % de
leurs employés qui ont
plus de 60 ans. Donc vraiment,
c'est une population
qui est assez importante
au sein de nos magasins,
mais on en prendrait plus.
- Mais le recrutement est
difficile, les aînés du Québec
sont moins nombreux sur
le marché du travail
qu'ailleurs au Canada.
Le taux d'emploi des 60 à 69 ans
est de 36 % dans la province,
alors qu'il est de 41 % dans
l'ensemble du pays et qu'il
dépasse les 42 % en Ontario.
Pourtant, cette main-d'oeuvre
serait bien utile par les temps
qui courent.
ROBERT GAGNÉ, Productivité
et la prospérité, HEC Montréal
- Si on avait le même taux
d'emploi pour les 60 ans et plus
qu'en Ontario, on pourrait
combler presque la moitié
des postes vacants actuellement
affichés au Québec.
- Selon l'étude effectuée par
HEC Montréal, les conventions
collectives dans les milieux
syndiqués, dont la fonction
publique, sont en partie
à blâmer. Elles contiennent
rarement des incitatifs pour
retenir les travailleurs âgés,
comme la modulation
des horaires, l'allègement
des tâches ou encore une semaine
de vacances supplémentaire pour
chaque année travaillée après
un certain âge, une pratique au
sein de plusieurs entreprises.
- Un travailleur de 64-65 ans
peut avoir jusqu'à 12 semaines
de vacances; il est là
40 semaines! Bien, c'est mieux
que zéro.
- Selon les auteurs de l'étude,
le Québec est mal préparé
pour faire face à la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre.
Ils estiment que les incitatifs
fiscaux sont insuffisants pour
convaincre les personnes âgées
de rester sur le marché
du travail et croient que les
seuils d'immigration auraient dû
être haussés davantage
depuis les années 2000.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, M